the Bay of Fundy in Eastern Canada has
the highest tides in the world anything
up to 16 meters difference between low
tide and high tide and the effects of
that shop in a few places around here
like Hopewell rocks where I'm not
standing on a beach right now I'm
standing on the ocean floor that's how
far the tide is out actually I'm kind of
sinking into it but in a few hours time
those rocks will be halfway underwater
and if I stuck around I would be
drowning in very cold very fast and very
deep ocean
but I'm not going to do that instead I'm
going to go about 40 kilometers that way
to Moncton it's the next morning it is
very cold and I'm flying a drone to try
and get a shot of the tidal bore this is
one of the few places in the world where
every high tide a wave of water washes
Upstream against the current but the
most obvious sign of the tides around
here is in Saint John at the reversing
falls where a massive river meets the
Bay of Fundy at a narrow channel filled
with rocks and snags this isn't just a
tidal River it's a tidal set of Rapids
calling it a waterfall is maybe a bit
generous but at low tide the water
definitely has a gradient it drops a
couple meters in height over a really
short distance and then a few hours
later at high tide the whole flow
reverses and the river's dropping a few
meters in height the other way and so
the obvious question I had was why has
nobody turned that bay into a power
station yet
actually question number one why are the
tides so high here to answer that I'll
use the bathtub in my hotel room for
this scientifically rigorous
demonstration the Bay of Fundy is
represented by the bathtub and the
Atlantic tides and all the unimaginable
pressure created by Mega tons of water
is represented by my arm so Moon Pools
on the ocean tide comes in pressure gets
applied
on a wave heads down the bathtub the
bear Fundy and bounces back because it's
not like the water all Rises
simultaneously it takes time and yes the
scale here is colossally different but
you still got a wave effect a reflection
and a trough that follows the wave tick
talk
tick
Tock and that will always take roughly
the same time to go up and bounce back
it'll be effects a little bit by the
weather and water temperature
so what happens when the next tide comes
in if I Time Each push to go with the
wave that's already there then very
quickly you start seeing a resonant
frequency and a lot of power
that worked way better than I expected
to the resonant frequency of the Bay of
Fundy is roughly 12 and a half hours the
same as the tidal cycle combine that
with geography that's less like a
bathtub and more like a funnel getting
Tighter and Tighter as that wave comes
in and you have the highest tides in the
world right there the power is immense
and it's obvious and if it could be
harnessed then it'll be reliable and
renewable intermittent sure but on a
schedule that would be simple for the
grid to predict and plan around so why
aren't there tidal power stations all
around the Bay of Fundy
well the answer is it's been tried a lot
usually in the minus Basin where several
companies have put millions and millions
of dollars behind technical trials and
every time the Bay of Fundy breaks the
turbines 2009 a turbine was torn apart
2010 two blades broken off 2018 damaged
Beyond repair turbines in these Waters
have to be light enough to spin but
strong enough to resist high-speed salt
water that carries huge amounts of
sediment and big rocks along with it and
in winter in almost chunks of sea ice oh
and that's before we even start talking
about the concerns from First Nations
people and Commercial Fishing operations
that may be putting a load of giant
spinning things in the water might cause
some problems for fish but people are
still trying there are more experimental
turbines planned can it be done
maybe I thought about doing long
interviews with the tidal power
companies and their opponents around
here but those interviews would have
sounded the same 20 years ago and the
result would just be a much longer way
of saying maybe if it can ever be done
safely and reliably it'll be brilliant I
hope that happens
but there's also a decent chance that
the Bay of Fundy is just going to tear
the turbines apart again and in 20 years
the answer will still be maybe
and now today's sponsor I saved 200 on
the rental car that got me here because
I use nordvpn turns out some car rental
companies charge locals more same car
same contracts saying everything I went
all the way to the final checkout to
make sure but because I click nordvpn's
magic button that let me pretend I was
still back in the UK I got quoted the UK
price which is a lot cheaper I've no
idea why but that one transaction was
worth way more than what I paid for a
two-year subscription plus being in
Canada some British sites keep trying to
be helpful and automatically redirect me
to dot CA domains or even occasionally
say that I can't access them at all
because I'm not a local now I can say my
phone or laptop are in the UK or any one
of about 60 other countries if I want
and a lot of stuff just works for me on
my laptop and my phone up to six devices
at the same time if I wanted if you go
to nordvpn.com Tom Scott you'll find the
best deal they're currently offering and
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee
just in case you change your mind the
same way this waterfall changes
Direction